Marvel's MCU has had an incredible run
starting off in 2008 with the Seminole
Ironman the franchise has grown to
become the biggest cinematic universe in
movie history
the creative team have pushed the
boundaries in several ways and whilst
their work is often imitated it is
unrivaled after watching through the
entirety of the MCU twice yes
twice I've ranked the film's from worst
to best this was a labor of love and
took a lot of time so whether you agree
or disagree with my list please let me
know your favorites without the way I'm
definition and this is my ranking of the
MCU door the weakest of the MCU Thor
centers around the origin of the god of
thunder starring Chris Hemsworth Natalie
Portman and Anthony Hopkins this film
tells the tale of Thor traveling to
earth after being cast out of his realm
as God suffering from an underdeveloped
love story and wick third act
Thor fails to really deliver on the
quality that the MCU has been known for
The Incredible Hulk The Incredible Hulk
was a course correction from the
previous Angley version starring Ed
Norton and distributed by Universal this
movie feels almost alien to the rest of
the MCU and once the film start off
excellently it devolved into a rather
banal and predictable climax that makes
it easily skippable in the overall run
Ironman to the weakest of the Ironman
trilogy this film suffered heavily due
to the writers strike I still really
enjoy it but this clearly problems in
the film and this is definitely the
worst Black Widow performance this movie
struggles with a sophomore curse and
feels like a step down from the seminal
film that preceded it Thor the dark
world Thor the dark world has gotten
better with age but it's still
criminally under uses it's film and
feels like a stopgap between Avengers
movies it betters these of its
protagonists as opposed to its
predecessor but certainly doesn't do
enough good to rank higher in this list
shame as there's a lot of cool character
moments that really make the god of them
they're infinitely more endearing
Captain America the First Avenger the
only period piece from the MCU Captain
America the First Avenger perfectly
introduces one of Comics longest-running
characters featuring a brilliant villain
in Red Skull his film depicts the cat
taking on Nazis in World War two it
completely deconstruct how cap was used
as propaganda in the war whilst nailing
down the fundamentals of what it takes
to be a hero this lays the groundwork
for what is to come and there's a
brilliant job with the source material
Iron Man 3
Iron Man 3 deals with a lot of heavy
subject matter such as post-traumatic
stress disorder and politics were it not
for the neck jerking twist that comes at
the film's midpoint this movie would
rank a lot higher it features astounding
action scenes and balances the drama
beautifully with comedy it's just a
shame that there was some inexcusable
choices that means this movie ranks far
down the list Doctor Strange Doctor
Strange introduces magic to the MCU and
does so in stunning fashion the
incredible visuals and performance by
Benedict Cumberbatch really captured my
imagination on first viewing and this
film has stayed with me over time
relying rather heavily on the Marvel
formula and being quite derivative of
Batman Begins early on keeps this film
below the rest but there's still a lot
to like here
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 guardians
2 misses out on meaning more due to its
clear derivative aspects of The Empire
Strikes Back this is a fun film but it
fails to capitalize fully on its
predecessor emotionally feeling
shallower points I struggle slightly
with this film but there's a lot of fun
aspects that evolved the characters in
more ways than one and anything with
baby grouping deserves some credit and
Matt ant-man heavily follows the Marvel
formula
but poles are often a much better way
than dr. strange does in my opinion
laced with jokes this comedy is
laugh-out-loud funny and has the visual
flair to match never before had we seen
a character that was able to shrink down
to atom size and the unique perspective
that the hero provides makes this an
endearing film in what is cinemas
biggest franchise age of Ultron age of
Ultron is a guilty pleasure of mine it
develops a central cast in more ways
than one and features amazing battle
scenes such as the opener and Hulkbuster
fight this film really pits
Tony against the rest of the team and
starts the divide that would come to
fruition in Civil War disliked at the
time due to the amount of plot threads
that leaves dangling this film works
better in retrospect and definitely
deserves a revisit now that we have all
of the information on the table
guardians of the galaxy
guardians was a huge risk for Marvel
this cast of characters were practically
unknown to all but the most die-hard
Marvel fans due to amazing casting and
raised a job writing the Guardians were
able to stand center stage in the MCU
and compete with the a-listers that
surrounded them the film made several of
its stars household names and is
hilarious from start to finish
it also teases a lot of what is to come
and is as good today as it was upon
release Captain America the Winter
Soldier Captain America the Winter
Soldier is a conspiracy theorists dream
possessing huge reveals from start to
finish this film really cemented cap is
one of the most remarkable characters in
the MCU and it's a blast from beginning
to end
centering around the captain's
relationship with former ally Bucky
Barnes the movie has a heart to it that
is near unrivaled it would go on to play
a hard part of the Marvel Universe and
definitely feels more adult in tone than
the other films in the genre making it
better every time you watch it black
panther black panther now stands as one
of the highest-grossing movies ever made
it's no surprise as the story has a
superhero like no other and a complex
villain that provides a lot of
thought-provoking discussion on aspects
such as race and revolution I was blown
away by the film upon first viewing and
the
stands as a milestone not only for its
phenomenal profit but also for the fact
that it is the first film to really
bring representation of Africa to
Hollywood in such a positive light
spider-man homecoming spider-man
homecoming is by far the best webhead
movie ever made this highschool centric
film perfectly captures Peter Parker
having to deal with his dual identity
whilst trying to live a normal life
Michael Keaton delivers a standout
performance as the antagonist and
there's several action scenes that
beautifully showcase Spidey's full range
of abilities this one isn't to be missed
and this outstanding coming-of-age story
is relatable on many levels that cement
it as one of the best Thor Ragnarok Thor
Ragnarok completely reinvents the
Thunder God character and is all the
better for it
playful apps this futuristic AES retro
action-adventure takes a lot of the
right boxes and manages to incorporate
several legendary graphic novels such as
Planet Hulk beautifully into its arc
Jeff Goldblum will have you
side-splitting
cog will have you on the floor and by
the film's end you will view the
characters in a way like never before
this film works great on several levels
and is a blast from start to finish
Ironman the first film in the MCU really
knocked it out the park in my opinion
Ironman is a masterpiece in terms of
casting pace and effects it nails the
Marvel formula right off the bat and is
a character defining journey from
beginning to end well I love about
Ironman is that it captures your
imagination from the get-go and leaves
you wanting more the movie beautifully
teases the Avengers but to works
perfectly is a standalone piece I can't
really fault the film and this is one of
the best The Avengers
The Avengers film was a trendsetter
responsible for all shared universe
films that would try and copy it success
this still stands as the best the
dialogue provided by Joss Whedon is
perfect and it cannot be credited enough
for the influence that would have on
films and the comic book genre following
its release this was a worldwide
phenomenon and was a landmark moment in
movie history that has argued
one of its most important the film was a
bouncing act but it manages to pull it
all off perfectly and catapults this
film to the forefront Avengers infinity
war ten years in the making
Avengers infinity war is an ambitious
crossover that manages to succeed in its
goals of uniting the Marvel Universe to
tackle the threat of Thanos beautifully
paced acted and presented the film is an
instant classic due to the bills
relatability and the epic battle scenes
that span it's two and a half hour
runtime I was blown away by how poetic
and emotionally charged the film was and
somehow it balances all of this gravitas
with a humorous side that will appeal
even to the most stone-hard infinity war
is an incredible triumph and one of the
best Marvel films ever created Captain
America Civil War Captain America Civil
War is incredible from start to finish
picking the Marvel cast of characters
against one another it perfectly
balances action with drama and has many
thought-provoking aspects that discuss
how all actions have consequences
both sides of the argument have their
pros and cons and it's easy to get
caught up in debates of privacy and
foreign policy when watching this film
at its heart this is a story of
friendship and it's one that I
constantly come back to because of its
incredible character development
it introduces spider-man black panther
and much more and it's my favorite MCU
film
as with all of my lists I'd love to hear
your thoughts what's your top five have
you seen infinity war and if so what did
you think of the film as always you can
comment below and let me know make sure
you subscribe to my channel as I do
movie discussions and interpretations
weekly and they'll definitely be
something on the channel that you love I
recently created a Snyder cup version of
the Justice League using several of the
deleted scenes from the film so make
sure you check that out if you enjoy
comic book movies as always I'm
definition thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]